[Music]
on this thursday night the push to pull
back the curtain america's top
prosecutor moves to unseal the search
warrants on donald trump's florida home
i personally approve the decision to
seek a search warrant brutal beating the
man attacked in his own driveway and how
his mother is being hailed a hero
from state of the art to shred it apart
inside the world's largest cargo plane
destroyed by russia's war
plus he was their super fan and good
luck charm you guys win the game the
emotional goodbye to a bright light for
the edmonton oilers
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us just three days after the
unprecedented search of former president
donald trump's florida mansion the
united states top prosecutor has
delivered a brief yet impactful address
to the nation in his first public
statement since the fbi descended on
trump's mar-a-lago estate attorney
general merrick garland says he's filed
a request to make the sealed files
related to the search public
the department filed the motion
to make public the warrant and receipt
in light of the former president's
public confirmation of the search
the surrounding circumstances and the
substantial public interest in this
matter
upholding the rule of law means applying
the law evenly
without fear
or favor
under my watch that is precisely what
the justice department is doing
know exactly when the documents will be
unsealed remains unknown but even
without their full release this move
marks a willingness by garland to refute
what he calls unfounded attacks from the
american right jackson prosco is
following this developing story for us
tonight jackson
well farah trump and his allies have
been assailing the justice department
for days now baselessly claiming the fbi
planted evidence after suggesting the
search warrant served at trump's
mar-a-lago home on monday was
unnecessary now in filing to unseal the
search warrant the department of justice
is seeking to let the public know
exactly what they were searching for the
warrant will detail the location
searched and the items searched for
what's key here though is that the doj's
motion to unseal says the court should
do so absent any objection from the
former president remember trump has had
these documents since monday and has so
far chosen not to release them a judge
has just ordered the justice department
to talk to trump's lawyers by tomorrow
to find out whether trump will object to
the release of the search warrant farah
jackson attorney general garland also
said he personally authorized the search
warrant so what else do we know about
earlier efforts to retrieve these
classified government documents from
trump
well there are reports that trump
received a subpoena in the spring for
the sensitive documents believed to be
in his possession these are documents he
allegedly failed to turn over earlier
this year when he was asked and agreed
to return some 15 boxes taken from the
white house now reports suggest the
documents were so sensitive to national
security that the department of justice
felt it had no choice but to execute a
search warrant to recover them which the
attorney general hinted at today
the department does not take such
decision lightly
where possible it is standard practice
to seek less intrusive means
as an alternative to a search and to
narrowly scope any search that is
undertaken in a statement tonight trump
claimed his attorneys were cooperating
with the doj all along and that
authorities simply got quote way ahead
of themselves but pharah he did not say
whether he will oppose unsealing the
warrant
jackson brosko in washington thank you
jackson police in ohio say they shot and
killed a suspect who allegedly tried to
break into the fbi office in cincinnati
investigators say the armed man
approached the visitor screening area
but took off when confronted by agents
the suspect who was wearing body armor
abandoned his car on a country road
leading to an hour-long standoff with
police there are reports that the
suspect may have had ties to the january
6th attack on the capitol
u.s officials say the canadian at the
center of this week's amber alert
entered the states illegally by driving
through a barbed wire fence officials
say benjamin martin moore a convicted
sex offender crossed the saskatchewan
montana border with a woman and her two
children u.s border patrol agents found
a cut fence and alerted rcmp moore was
taken into custody in south dakota on
wednesday the children were found safe
their mother is also said to be in
custody in the u.s
there is a war of words going on over
the state of health care in canada's
biggest province staffing shortages have
led to some surgeries being canceled and
even some hospitals closing their doors
frontline workers say the system is in
crisis but as mike trolley reports
ontario's health minister doesn't see it
that way
ontario's health minister had to see
this coming question after question
about staff shortages in hospitals my
question to the minister of health
reflect on what it would be like to be
unable to breathe how many hours will
londoners have to wait and whether the
government was looking to privatization
as a solution no no no talking to
reporters an embattled sylvia jones
acknowledge staffing is an issue but
bristled at the use of the word crisis
let's be clear
there is not a crumbling system in the
province of ontario the issue came to a
head this past weekend with two ottawa
hospitals having to temporarily close
their ers
a similar situation is playing out in
clinton ontario which was forced to shut
the doors to its er today an accident
can happen at any time and if it's not
available it could be
it could be life or death when it
reopens friday it will have limited
hours we're running at about half the
nurses that we need
to
open this department on a 24-hour basis
so it's really concerning the pressures
are significant the burnout is an issue
and a concern for us the wellness of our
team
major major issues so we make these
decisions obviously not lightly but
they're right for weeks now catherine
hoy of the ontario nurses association
has been traveling around the province
to see the situation firsthand
she has no qualms about calling it a
crisis my phone blows up day and night
surgery is being canceled
and we heard that that isn't happening
but it is
the nurses union says the system needs
30 000 new hires in ontario and
financial incentives to keep the 23
percent of its members who are eligible
for retirement from walking away
frontline workers insist the crisis is
real and if it gets any worse the health
minister may have no choice but to agree
mike delay global news toronto
before we introduce our next story a
warning that some people might find it
disturbing
police in brampton ontario are looking
for a group of men who attacked a
punjabi media personality in his own
driveway security video shows three
assailants dragging the man out of his
car
jyoti singh man was badly beaten just
days after receiving a death threat as
sean o'shea reports this isn't the first
attack within the community this year
the video is difficult to watch the man
in the jeep on his driveway in brampton
ontario approached by three masked men
armed with an axe and machete they
dragged him out and beat him repeatedly
the brutal attack captured on a home
security camera when i saw the video it
was so shocking for me
neighbors watched it later online we've
blurred the graphic images but the man's
mother saw it all unfold
so they came she's saying they were here
to kill him
and he grabbed one of the weapons but
they overpowered him obviously with
three of them and then one of them
grabbed the legs and continued to hack
away at his foot
she ran to her son to help and may have
saved his life
and boy
was his mother
a hero what courage she showed she ran
out it was a pure
reaction on her part and it certainly
helped contribute to him still being
here today jody singh man is well known
here a local real estate agent and
prominent punjabi media personality
police confirmed he'd received a death
threat on the phone days earlier a
safety plan was put in place with the
victim at the time
that the death threat was reported to us
but mann didn't receive police
protection in time the mayor says man's
family has asked for help again after
the attack when the attack happened i
got a call from the family who
wanted protection from the police police
are still investigating motive but this
is the third physical attack in the last
year on people who work in the media in
brampton question how safer media
personalities are
in giving the news and you know giving
commentary as well for now police are
left trying to assure the community it
was a targeted attack police say
additional video may solve this case and
so they've appealed to neighbors to
check their dash cams for now jody singh
mann remains in hospital with serious
and life-changing injuries shawn o'shea
global news brampton ontario
new satellite images show major damage
at an air base in russian-controlled
crimea after a string of deadly
explosions on tuesday before and after
images revealed deep craters from what
appeared to be a precise attack nine
military jets were destroyed according
to the ukrainian government russia is
denying any damage ukraine has not
claimed responsibility but the attack
suggests keeve may have obtained new
long-range strike capability ukraine's
ministry of defense is also warning
russians not to visit crimea
the largest plane in the world was
destroyed when russia invaded ukraine in
february the loss at the antonov maria
was not only a cultural and
technological blow to ukraine but the
entire aviation community
efforts are underway to salvage parts
from the engineering marvel but it's
painstaking work our europe bureau chief
crystal command saying was granted a
rare inside look at the monumental task
ahead
she last took to the sky one year ago
performing a fly pass celebrating
ukraine's independence day
now she lies in ruins on this airfield
mechanism vladimir smooth scours the
wreckage for recognizable pieces of the
maria the plane that made antonov a
world famous aviation company the
gigantic plane lies in sections and
staff are scattered around salvaging
parts
along with the antonov spokesperson
global news was granted a rare view from
inside yeah
he says i just came here for the first
time the site is overwhelming the maria
was the world's largest cargo plane
holding more than 100 world records
including the heaviest payload ever
lifted
the key employees do not really like to
be photographed in front of the
background of the destroyed maria the
rebuilding effort is underway it's a
priority for the company and the nation
but what happened at this site is under
investigation by ukrainian authorities
russian forces targeted the antonov
airport on day one of the invasion
the helicopters flew at extremely low
altitudes rose from behind the forest
belt and opened fire on the objects of
the antonov airport
as he watched paratroopers drop onto the
airfield he gave the order to return
fire kalia
when i see all destroyed russian
equipment it makes me happy the
ukrainians he says were dominated from
the air without artillery support they
were soon outnumbered and forced to pull
back the maria was just one of the
casualties of the fierce and bloody
battle that raged here for weeks ukraine
eventually reclaimed the
we were area prepared for war they
figured some missile strikes were
possible but not an invasion of the
airfield
widely shared video shows russian forces
seizing the airport and all of the
buildings
but for this long time employee the
video isn't necessary
he was there that day is that this
building
so those staircases
is that therapy
yes it's believed the goal was to create
a russian base within striking distance
of keith the main administration
building here at the airport is pretty
much destroyed this was the air traffic
control tower as you can see there's
really not much left of any of it
russian forces stormed this
administration building they use the
control tower area as a lookout point
from here they could not only see the
airfield but also hostimel
european
and over that way bucha as russian
forces arrived civilians nearby suffered
tremendously as russians were unable to
push forward to the capitol homes were
looted in the region people were beaten
killed
or taken hostage rudenko says some of
his men who defended the airport remain
in captivity he wouldn't say how many
what he did say about the russian
captors is unsparing
all of you will be in fire
the emotions fueled the desire to
rebuild the maria bigger and better a
new symbol of ukraine
and its endurance
crystal commansing global news hostile
male ukraine
an ominous warning about security coming
up what the rcmp wants mps to know plus
canadian tennis fans serve up some love
to serena williams
canada's national police force has
issued a stark warning to members of
parliament global news has learned that
the rcmp have briefed federal
politicians to advise them foreign
actors are likely monitoring their
digital devices our auto bureau chief
mercedes stevenson has been digging into
this and she joins us now with the
latest mercedes what do we know about
the threat to politicians
so far we got curious about this after
we heard the rcmp speaking at a
committee earlier this week talking
about the ability the rcmp has to turn
on the camera or the microphone on
canadian cell phones in criminal
investigations and we started to wonder
well if the rcmp could do that could
someone else do that what about our
politicians and we heard from a senior
rcmp official there who said they have
told politicians this could be a threat
so we asked the rcmp what they're doing
to protect parliamentarians and here's
what they told us they said that on an
ad hoc basis in the past or when
requested the rcmp has provided
parliamentarians with briefings
regarding the vulnerabilities of
wireless technologies and smart devices
they said that these investigations are
multifaceted and could or would include
investigation of foreign surveillance
efforts of various types they wouldn't
specify what states they're worried
about but a lot of experts say russia
and china for two examples and they also
wouldn't tell us whether they've
actually found spyware on any
parliamentarians phones but it is
certainly something they're saying is a
significant concern for them okay coming
back to canada mercedes do we know if
any other agencies are using similar
techniques on canadians
well that's the next big question if we
know about the rcmp but we didn't before
who else is using it we talked to the
public safety minister marco menducino
today and asked him why this technology
is being used at all and if he's
comfortable with it here's what he told
us
look these investigative techniques
which are deployed by law enforcement
are
necessary given
the new sophisticated
lengths to which organized crime are
using encryption techniques and other
sophisticated technologies to avoid
being detected
so that is the minister defending it we
asked csis canada spy agency if they're
using this in a statement they told us
they take privacy considerations very
seriously and that robust safeguards are
set in place to ensure canadians rights
and freedoms they also said that they
use a variety of investigative
techniques but they wouldn't tell us
specifically whether or not they use
this one or whether or not there has
been a privacy investigation into
whether or not the use of any potential
technologies like this breach canadians
privacy rules okay mercedes stevenson
thank you
yep that's a tornado on fire ahead a
look at more raging wildfires in
california
while the state of emergency is staying
in force the wildfire situation in
newfoundland and labrador appears to be
stabilizing fire crews say the
paradise-like fire hasn't grown over the
past day and while the bay de spear fire
has shrunk a change in wind is allowing
for ground crews to safely tackle the
flames up until now most of the attacks
on the fires came from planes and
helicopters the improved conditions are
allowing for the major highway through
the area to remain open but drivers are
being warned smoke from the fires could
limit visibility
and across large parts of southern
british columbia all eyes are on the
skies as forecast storms could bring
lightning strikes and spark new fires
fire crews are getting the upper hand on
the carameus creek fire and evacuation
orders for 54 homes have now been
rescinded but nearly 500 families are
still out of their homes
all the smoke has now prompted a special
air quality statement for the okanagan
valley
at the same time one of the major
highway routes through the bc interior
was closed after a mudslide caused by a
sudden rainstorm the mud and debris
blocked a section of the transcanada
between litton and spence's bridge an
area where there have been multiple
wildfires over the past few summers
crews are on scene working to clear the
mud and reopen the route
a brush fire that erupted in california
grew so fast its heat and wind generated
a smoke nato
the fire broke out south of bakersfield
and quickly engulfed more than 40
hectares at its height more than 200
firefighters were working to put it out
the cause of the brush fire is still
under investigation but crews say it's
already 80 percent contained
remembering the biggest little oilers
fan next as six-year-old ben stelter
inspired the hockey world
like i said in my article i'm terrible
at goodbyes but uh
goodbye
[Applause]
toronto
that's tennis legend serena williams
with heartfelt goodbyes to a standing
ovation at the national bank open in
toronto last night after wrapping up her
final match on canadian soil the sports
icon recently announced she's retiring
after she competes at the u.s open in a
few weeks williams received a few
retirement gifts on her way out of the
six though she and her daughter were
both given maple leafs and raptors
jerseys
the hockey world is mourning the loss of
a beloved six-year-old superfan who
inspired fans and players alike
ben stelter died after a brave battle
with brain cancer his loyalty lied with
the edmonton oilers but everyone was
cheering for ben
as dan grumman reports the young boy
made the most of his time on the ice
[Applause]
he wasn't the first kid to stand on the
blue line alongside his favorite players
but ben stelter's time as an honorary
edmonton oiler lasted long after the
national anthem finished
the little boy who was diagnosed with an
aggressive form of brain cancer at age
four quickly captured the hearts of
hockey fans and became a regular at home
games
fans even chanted his name
look at that
i'm all cheering for you the team
embraced him too inviting him to
practice into the dressing room and once
awarding him the game mvp helmet
it didn't hurt he was a good luck charm
the oilers would go the rest of the
regular season undefeated with ben in
the building he's been a
real inspiration for us and i mean you
can tell i mean we've been rallying
around him but ben's infectious smile
laugh and attitude masked what he was
going through ben stelzer is in the
building tonight five-year-old ben is a
fighter thought he did
until he no longer could
ben's father posted the news on twitter
writing our hearts are left with a ben
sized hole in them and life will never
be the same without you we are
absolutely crushed it was a
an amazing um
amazing little guy who lit up every
single room he was in
certainly lit up our room he's going to
be greatly missed what he went through
really puts everything into perspective
and you guys win the game let's get kids
up
much of sports is about rivalries ben
loved the oilers but everyone cheered
for ben
a little boy who made a big impact in
the hockey world with limited ice time
good job you'll get your next year dan
grumman global news edmonton
and that's global national for this
thursday night i'm farah nasser and on
behalf of our whole crew i want to thank
you so much for spending part of your
evening with us tonight's york canada is
the village of campbellton newfoundland
and labrador we love seeing your canada
so please keep emailing us your pictures
to viewers at globalnational.com
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other good night
[Music]